we think that you know you're one degree
away from basically almost any Mentor
you want in the world and that they are
much easier to get than you could ever
imagine just everybody does it wrong
because they take a shotgun approach
right so it's DM dmdm dmdm yeah low
level unspecific non-tailored
non-value-added Outreach and they wonder
why it doesn't work when you want to get
a high value Target what do you do do
you ever shoot at them with a shotgun no
you have a sniper rifle you spend a ton
of time on the preparation for it it's
called prepping the environment and you
would want to make sure that the wind
direction is correct you want to make
sure the sun is correct and it's the
same thing I think when you want
something out of life including
mentorship